a los alrededores del estadio hans dos
kamikazes se acaban de inmolar en un
intervalo de diez minutos un tercero lo
hará menos de media hora más tarde son
las 9 30 de una noche de horror que
acaba de empezar el presidente françois
hollande que existía el partido amistoso
entre francia y alemania es evacuado y
descubre entonces la situación en el
centro de parís hay ataques en los
distritos 10 y 11 de la capital tiroteos
en terrazas de cafés bares y
restaurantes de la calle oliver calle de
la fonte nova y calle de lanzaron en los
barrios festivos de la ciudad decenas de
ciudadanos son asesinados por soltar
tour había sangre en todas partes las
personas caían como moscas se enrede
será una verdadera escena de guerra
tenía la impresión de estar en una
trinchera pero el ataque más mortal no
había empezado a las 9 49 mientras 1500
personas asisten a un concierto de rock
en bataclán tres asaltantes irrumpen en
la sala abriendo fuego con automáticas
un periodista del món vecino filmó esta
escena algunas personas logran escapar
por una puerta trasera otros se cuelgan
de las ventanas en el interior muchos a
veces más de 20 se esconden en pequeñas
salas
dos policías los primeros en llegar al
lugar matan a uno de los atacantes en la
planta baja los otros dos están
atrincherados en el primer piso con los
rehenes las brigadas de búsqueda e
intervención de la policía toman el
relevo cuando finalmente se libera la
planta baja los rescatados salen
aterrorizados con éxito sus armas y las
que estábamos todos tumbados y vi que
disparaban hacia todos lados así sale el
instinto de supervivencia todos estamos
en el suelo no nos movemos quisiéramos
entrar enterrarnos en el suelo para que
no nos vean o para con un juan osorio y
software con villegas estábamos unos
sobre los otros en cogidos mientras
oíamos los tiros de kalashnikov como si
torturaron a gente la gente sufría
porque les disparaban era una carnicería
una matanza gente muerta en todas partes
hacia la medianoche françois hollande
solemne se dirige a los franceses y su
compatriota
como el exprimer
queridos compatriotas en este momento
ataques terroristas de un alcance sin
precedentes tienen lugar en parís está
diciendo
y ya hay decenas de muertos y muchos
heridos es un horror
soy uno en el bataclán tras intentar
detenidamente negociar con los
terroristas los policías asaltan la sala
son las 12 y 21 minutos de la noche y la
operación ha finalizado terminan así
tres horas sangrientas nunca antes
francia había recibido un ataque
parecido